[Musica]
alzi la mano chi pensa che nella propria
casa ma anche qualcosa
ora
alzi la mano chi vorrebbe fare qualche
modifica ma non sta da dove partire
dalla signora la signora vedo motivata
Ok ora alzi la mano chi non ha alzato la
mano
Ok voi tutti fuori
sto scherzando arredare è una cosa
superficiale
ma arredare in realtà è una cosa potente
perché l'arredo ha un enorme impatto
nelle nostre vite oggi vi svelerò la mia
formula Ed insieme faremo un viaggio
sensoriale e un esercizio che poi
potrete mettere in pratica questa sera a
casa vostra è un vero e proprio
Esercizio mentale
Questo è quello che accade nella mente
delle persone quando si arreda a casa
[Musica]
una casa che non ci rispecchia o
incompleta è spesso fonte di confusione
e di malessere
adesso
chiudete gli occhi e seguite ogni mia
parola vi vedo chiudete gli occhi se non
funziona
venite con me in una casa per un
sopralluogo
Entrate ora nella mia mente
mi trovo davanti alla porta di casa
suono e la porta si apre
entro e nella mia testa quando faccio un
sopralluogo inizia una piacevole melodia
Guardiamo insieme la casa a darmi il
benvenuto un lungo corridoio
con una console in stile moderno dalle
linee pulite
color legno chiaro su di essa sulla
sinistra c'è una grande lampada da
tavolo con base in cemento grezzo la
superficie la vedete è ruvida grigia
dietro alla lampada c'è un quadro con
disegnato il profilo di un cavallo
stilizzato e al centro del ripiano della
console un pesante fermacarte nero
sembra forma di cavallo che va a fermare
una serie di libri vedete tutto è
piacevole e armonioso e adesso faccio
altre due passi e vedo un tavolo Siamo
nella zona living un raggio di luce
illumina il tavolo con sopra un
bicchiere dentro c'è dell'acqua con del
ghiaccio
che ha creato un po' di condensa Sento
il freddo nella mia mano che bello che
bere un bicchier d'acqua frizzante con
una scorza di limone in una calda
giornata di estate come oggi
Dite la verità
state deglutendo che ha deludito
vi è aumentata la salivazione bene Vuol
dire che il test sta funzionando e che
vi state immedesimando al 100%. ora
continuate a tenere gli occhi chiusi
state con me nella stanza
volgiamo lo sguardo a destra e
all'improvviso Sono colpita dai
chiassosi colori di un grande quadro in
stile bohemien con di fianco un divano
in pelle verde marcio con sopra dei
cuscini con sopra anche dei Girasoli
non c'è più melodia non c'è più melodia
ma solo rumore
ora Aprite gli occhi
La verità è che ogni parte della casa
della vostra casa è legata da un film
Rouge non ci devono essere elementi di
disturbo strutturali oppure di design
tutto fa parte di un'unica sinfonia
e per arredare la vostra casa in modo
che sia armoniosa in modo che vi faccia
sentire bene È importante percepirla e
che voi la percepite come una canzone
che non viene mai interrotta come un
flusso di continuità di elementi e
colori che crea in voizione
un'armonia leggera che vi accompagna
stanza per stanza e che racconta di voi
pensate nella musica abbiamo solo 7 note
Ok 12 per i musicisti però ne abbiamo
solo 7 ed è grazie a quel numero di note
che possiamo creare un numero infinito
di canzoni ma a questo punto mi state
chiedendo di sicuro ma come faccio io a
ottenere Quella sinfonia la sinfonia
giusta per arredare la mia casa bene Vi
ho promesso un segreto e vi svelo Il
Segreto la regola compositiva 60 30 10
questa regola è molto semplice e si basa
sulle percentuali
imparata questa regola Voi riuscirete a
bilanciare a casa vostra colori e
materiali Like a Pro all'interno della
vostra casa prima di tutto anche adesso
nella vostra mente identificate i colori
che vi fanno stare bene
aiutatevi Magari anche a casa con
riviste immagini foto oppure Scegliete
tessuti che vi possano fare da guida
i colori che sceglierete saranno le note
per creare la vostra canzone
Scegliete Quindi adesso il colore
principale che sarà il vostro 60 io
prediligo un colore neutro da utilizzare
per le pareti e per i macroelementi come
ad esempio il divano
ora Scegliete il colore secondario che
sarà il vostro 30 e io Vi suggerisco uno
dei miei colori preferiti che è
l'azzurro polvere
tinta perfetta da mixare anche con i
materiali come la pietra il marmo in
legno ed infine scegliete un colore a
100 che sarà il vostro 10 ed è questo il
colore che darà carattere a tutto e se
ci pensate sarà il ritornello della
vostra canzone Io amo utilizzare il nero
creando dei richiami attraverso per
esempio maniglie pomelli o anche solo i
profili di specchi o cornici ora con
questa regola compositiva 60 30 10 avete
la prova empirica che i colori siano le
note per creare la vostra canzone e
stasera
Grazie a questo esercizio inizierete a
guardare la vostra casa con occhi
diversi scoprirete la percentuale di
colori che avete utilizzato e magari
saprete come agire per sistemare qualche
errore
inizierete ad ascoltare la vostra casa
arredate e rinnovate la vostra casa con
gioia anche solo utilizzando Degli
arredi degli elementi che avete già da
oggi da qui da questo palco io vi voglio
ridare la libertà di creare la vostra
casa come volete perché un vostro
diritto è un vostro diritto un diritto
che avete perso da qualche parte per
strada in un momento non si sa bene
quando
avete il diritto di ridipingere una
parete Ma quanto tempo ci mettete a
prendere la decisione di dipingere una
parete
mesi anni fatelo cavolo
rafforzativo E se non vi piace datevi il
permesso di ridipingerla di nuovo
avete il diritto di arredare il vostro
più grande investimento la vostra casa
secondo la stagione della vita che state
vivendo
avete il diritto di spostare i mobili
tutte le volte che volete oggi vi do il
permesso io e quindi Qualunque sia la
regola Qualunque sia la stagione della
vita che state vivendo datevi il
permesso di essere creativi E siate i
compositori della vostra casa tu il
castello tu hai le regole Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]